what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here and I'm jonald we are going to
watch today from mr. Krupp just who
often comments on her channel lately
appreciate that buddy he's an amazing
youtuber avengers endgame logan style we
watched the first logan trailer already
I'm actually really interested to watch
this because he does he's awesome recut
but usually he does them for movies that
have already been released so he can
really mess with the footage I'm like
how are you gonna recut this with very
little footage to work off so one of our
top and war tears at our patreon is
whatever video you request and must
definitely do and put up on YouTube and
today comes from man Lance door at our
patreon we do weekly Q&A s John does
music video coverage and we do TV show
reaction watch the long floor shows like
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood my hero academia Riverdale
Gotham and supernatural so you like us
and you want more from us let's watch
as possible if you find this recording
for the journeys the end being adrift in
space was your own promise to rescue us
more funding sounds he's low goodness
yes at X 22 okay
okay
this is cool
Logan trail yeah dude Oh oh wait there's
more we cut it yes yeah subscribe to mr.
crap just immediately I so like normally
what he'll do is actually find like
clips or sequences that match though but
that's cuz it has the whole movie that
he could work off of you know that's a
little bit different here it was smart
of him to take footage from other MCU
films and infuse it into here to have
some of the emotional beats at home but
what he really got down hardcore was the
tone of it all I mean having a famous
Johnny Cash hurt song it really does
help compliment it but you know a lot of
that desolation a lot of that grieving
type of vibe yeah all is lost
the entirety of the end game trailers
that flavor so in a way he didn't even
really have to re-edit it that much you
just throw the song that's fun yeah that
feels like Logan because they both have
a certain element of desperation and a
very final struggle of sorts yeah and
then they both end in a way of all those
lost it feels very hopeless right now
but there's still one chance one more
chance you could take because the Logan
trailer ends on you know I so obvious
weird how obvious it was in the trailer
that he was burying Xavier I mean the
trailers make it clear
either way the Logan trailer ends on the
note of how it's like this is he's
clearly at his worst moment there Logan
yeah but there's still time Logan
there's still a chance and then he said
he flips that with Captain America we
still have one more like basically going
we we need one more chance yes we still
have to try hey you know what even some
of those visual things because in the
Logan trailer you have a decent amount
of shots inside the big old
silo's thing that xavier is in which
kind of me i was the ship that tony's in
a little bit especially on it's like
cavernous blueness yeah you know and
also he changes the text of the end game
to match the logan one yeah this is
really cool man
this is really cool that it's weirdly
it's like the her song could have worked
over the avengers endgame trailer
because he really didn't have to really
change it yeah it has that same kind of
emotional weight to it anyway thank you
mr. CREB this is an awesome video man
and another good job another recut type
of trailer I can't wait to see a recut
when you get footage of the full endgame
movie you know what you're gonna make
out of that what's not are gonna put
that in so guys if you haven't
subscribed mr. Krabs just do it right
now and it's a land store thank you so
much for being part of a patreon page
for so long my friend recently send me a
message he's a firefighter in Canada he
said our fire chief trained us right out
to become future instructors like him
one of our final test evaluations is to
do a 30-minute presentation on any topic
we choose I was actually thinking doing
like a YouTube topic along the lines of
use of history certain you know channel
and the funding I'm still undecided
though well dude if you're gonna do a
presentation which you got to know first
my first bit of advice is you have to
know why you're doing YouTube for
example for us only want popularity we
wanted subscribers because we do not
feel loved in our personal lives low
self-esteem very very low self-esteem
that's why when we get a positive
comment we feel joy and happiness unlike
anything we've ever felt outside of
being on camera and then we get a hate
comment that usually really hits home
because that's how we feel in general so
you really got to know why you want to
do YouTube secondly what kind of channel
are you looking to do are you looking to
do a YouTube channel about being a
firefighter I think that'd be cool cuz
there's a market for anything yeah
totally and that's an underserved niche
right there think about it fire fighting
vlogs you strap on your GoPro run into a
burning building and watch the view
counts sky ruff you could get a dead
body on camera dude Logan Paul whoa and
he's like one of the biggest YouTube
Roseanne Paul oh yeah he should be a
firefighter
that's what I'm thinking so along the
lines of YouTube history well you're
gonna have to talk to Jackie YouTube
about that yeah we don't really get to
talk to him too much but he's a good guy
now more than ever is the best time to
start I don't know if you've heard the
news starting your own channel brand new
now is the best time oh yeah
so get on the on the ground floor before
it blows up because you know in a couple
of years it's gonna be - boom it's gonna
hit it's gonna hit there's gonna be
oversaturated market people might pull
out their ads and they might start
favoring you know family-friendly videos
might yeah a really core fortunately
that hasn't happened yet yeah it's still
a Wild West to YouTube you know
fortunately everyone still gets our
subscribe button notifications so thanks
Lance anyway you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click the notification
bell & Tricks on patreon bye bye